liebe leute ich muss mal wieder dampf
ablassen was dann wieder in berlin
passiert spottet jeder beschreibung auf
der einen seite muss der
bundesverkehrsminister die zulassung von
zehntausenden a6 und a7 von audi mit
einem dreiliter dieselmotor zurück
ziehen wegen unzulässiger abschalt
software also betrug eine absolut
peinliche geschichte jetzt immer noch
aber noch peinlicher wird es wenn er auf
der anderen seite eine reduktion des co2
ausstoßes bei pkw und kleinen
nutzfahrzeugen um die hälfte bis achtung
nur 2030 ablehnt grund für mich mal
dampf abzulassen herzlich willkommen bei
gigs und salzen fiction
da geht mir echt einer ab der mann ist
doch offensichtlich ja abgas vergiftet
oder sowas andreas scheuer von der csu
seines zeichens verkehrsminister hat der
den schuss nicht gehört der man sagt
doch allen ernstes wir brauchen keine
willkürlichen politisch ideologischen
grenzwerte nach dem muster pi mal daumen
sondern realistische technisch machbare
grenzwerte die vernichtung einer
europäischen leitindustrie mache ich
nicht mit herzlich willkommen in
wolkenkuckucksheim
der mann hat offensichtlich noch nichts
von der klimakatastrophe gehört was
stimmt denn bei dem nicht die mal daumen
wir wissen noch mal wir wissen wir
hängen mit der reduzierung von co2
weltweit total hinterher von wegen pi
mal daumen und auch die bundesrepublik
wird trotz des niedergangs der industrie
im osten ihr selbstgestecktes ziel der
reduktion des kohlendioxid ausstoßes um
40 prozent um acht prozentpunkte also
tatsächlich 20 prozent verfehlen
was für ein fehler und dann sagt der
verkehrsminister noch so ein blödsinn
übersetzt lieber vernichten wir die erde
mit jedweder leitindustrie und unser
gleich mit und noch etwas kommt hinzu
und das hat die bundesumweltministerin
svenja schulze von der spd ganz gut
formuliert wenn die deutsche
autoindustrie mit alten technologien und
betrug software ihre existenz sichern
muss dann sehen sie sich den ast ab auf
dem sie sitzt schon jetzt gibt die
autoindustrie wohl bei der
batterieentwicklung auf und will diese
kerntechnologie wohl nur einkaufen und
stattdessen die audi stecken die
autohersteller weiterhin ihre kompetenz
in die programmierung von betrug
software
das kann doch nicht sein es ist schlimm
für die arbeiter und angestellten die
totengräber sind ihre chefs man darf
nicht vergessen dass die anstehenden
klagen die autokonzerne milliarden
kosten werden die klagen wegen der
preisabsprachen der lkw hersteller sind
furchtbar pro lkw wird die entschädigung
auf rund 8000 euro geschätzt und das
sind unmengen fahrzeuge die das betrifft
und dazu kommt der diesel skandal der
auch noch viele leben kosten
zehntausende tote pro jahr weltweit laut
einer studie sind es allein in europa
mehr als 10.000
die auf die betrug software zurück gehen
also drohte grauenhaft da ist es fast
ein trost wer nicht mit der zeit geht
geht mit der zeit die
entwicklungsabteilung bei den
autoherstellern
die tragen eine große schuld das
jahrelange beharren auf ihrem know-how
zu verbrennungsmotoren was aber in
zukunft nicht mehr gebraucht wird und
dazu noch die umschichtung der
umweltanforderungen durch kriminellen
betrug das ist die schlimme schuld die
die ingenieure und das management dort
auf sich geladen haben an menschenleben
und arbeitsplätzen nicht von ungefähr
landen immer mehr ingenieure und
automanager im gefängnis und wenn der
wandel kommt sind diejenigen die ihn
aushalten wollten meistens diejenigen
die den höchsten preis zahlen müssen
aber es gibt einen trost im bereich der
regenerativen energien gibt es immer
mehr arbeitsplätze mehr als 300.000 sind
es aktuell in deutschland und es werden
immer mehr was die arbeitsplätze in der
autoindustrie angeht das ist relativ
simpel zwei gefahren drohen hier der
deutschen automobilindustrie und hier
wird scheinbar geschlafen it-technologie
das zentrum der fahrzeuge von morgen
hier greifen apple und google und auch
tesla an
und zweitens der antrieb der
elektroantrieb oder auch der
wasserstoffantrieb wenn sie nicht exakt
in diesen bereichen aufpassen werden sie
den anschluss verlieren und wer sich an
da an solche petitessen wie dem co2
ausstoß aufhält hat einfach überhaupt
keinen plan
die mobilität wird sich in den nächsten
jahren massiv ändern
ich habe zum beispiel eine bahncard 100
und fahrer ein kleines elektroauto und
es gibt noch tausend andere
mobilitätskonzepte mit dem eigenen auto
im stau stehen ist jedenfalls kein
zukunftsmodell geschweige denn dabei
auch noch unseren planeten zu zerstören
lieberherr scheuer kleine erinnerung sie
sind bundesverkehrsminister und nicht
bundes auto minister ja wenn ihr kein
video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollte die
youtube abo box funktioniert ja einfach
nicht dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur
dann verpasst er kein video whatsapp
über web erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren
das geht hier da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt
für eben hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht
es war damit dafür auch draufklicken
elektroauto wahnsinn da lasse ich auch
mal dampf ab bis dann bleibt